- In the first round of today's
competition
you'll have to combine the
steel from that sprocket
with the steel of that
chain to make a billet,
from which to forge a signature
blade in your signature style.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Your three hour forge
time starts now.
Here we go.
Each of our bladesmiths
has a sprocket
that is mild steel and a
chain it is hardenable steel.
The chain's pretty obvious,
but the sprocket I think
is going to be confusing
them a little bit.
It looks like that would be a
nice chunk of hardenable steel,
but it's mild.
My plan for this
challenge, I'm
going to take that sprocket,
forge out a billet,
and I'm going to take some
of these damn chain links
and I'm going to forge
weld them into the spine.
I don't think Liam
realizes that sprocket
is mild, unhardenable
steel, and he's making
a complete blade out of it.
Oh, [inaudible].
You got that
sprocket Incorporated?
It's all sprocket.
I incorporated the chain.
I'm getting this blade
pretty much where I want it.
It feels good in the hand.
You can tell where
the links are.
I want to do a good
thermal cycling,
and then give it a good quench.
Can you thermal cycle mild
steel to make it harder?
- No.
Liam's in the quench.
Moment of truth.
And the file doesn't skate.
It doesn't harden.
If the metal's not
hard, it'll fold
when it hits the ice block.
Round two.
How do we get high
carbon steel on the edge
of Liam's blade, Dave?
How?
You build a time machine.
You travel back three hours.
Liam, with a second quench.
Is it still biting?
It's still biting
a little bit.
Mine is, too.
What's your edge steel?
The sprocket.
I just forge-welded
in the links.
Chain is normally mild steel.
No, it's hard.
I ground every tooth
off my sprocket.
I'm not too convinced that
it's hardenable steel.
Well, that's what
this all is, then.
Good luck.
Now I'm second guessing
my steel selection,
using the sprocket for my edge.
I run over to the acid tank,
give my blade a quick dip,
and that's when I notice it.
[bleep]
Liam forged an entire
blade that is mild steel.
[bleep]
- Is that going to cut?
- No.
It'd make a good butter knife.
I just wasted three
hours making a really cool
looking knife that isn't
going to hold an edge.
I could be going home.
But, you know what?
I've had bigger hurdles and
bigger struggles in my life.
I've battled depression.
I've battled PTSD.
I've buried more friends to
suicide than I have to combat.
At this point in time,
I've got what I've got.
I just need to move forward.
It will have to do.
My biggest concern going
into judging, it's my steel.
I potentially made a
catastrophic mistake
by using the wrong
metal to make a blade.
Bladesmiths, the first
round of competition is over.
Now it's time for
the judges to take
a closer look at your work.
Ethan, you're up first.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
Well, Ethan, I
really like to shape.
I like that you gave
us a lean piece.
You've got a pretty
good curve in the blade
there that needs
to be addressed.
Liam, you're next.
First up, Liam,
I love this design.
It's almost like a kukri.
Forward heavy, so that means
you have to really take
care of that handle, that
when I go forward with this,
something's got to stop it
from flying out of my hand.
You file checked this?
File checked it
the first time.
It skated in a couple of spots.
Do you have an idea what
that sprocket material was?
I'm guessing it was a
chromium alloy of some type.
Thank you.
Evan, you're up.
Evan, I like the
profile overall.
You've got a swell on the top
and bottom, in the midsection,
and a flare on the back.
And that's exactly what
I like to see on a knife
that I'm going to
be swinging around.
But I see chain
all through this.
Where is the sprocket?
My plan with the sprocket
was to weld on bolsters.
I wish I could have
done a San Mai,
but I was fooling too
much with the chain.
So just to be clear,
there is only one
type of metal in this blade?
Yes, sir.
OK.
Thank you.
Evan, by failing to
combine your two steels
together to form
that signature blade,
you fail to meet parameters.
For that reason, I have to
ask you to leave the forge.